here is
the view
and it's the original clip that we did
our cold open with this is the ladies of
the view basically calling for tulsi and
tucker to be investigated and
potentially arrested
but i think that's an incredibly
relevant question and i think doj in the
same way that it is uh setting up a task
force to investigate oligarchs should
look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
that's being if you are a foreign asset
to a dictator it should be investigated
in fact i remember when tulsi gabbard
and i even hate that we're discussing it
because i think to myself who is this
woman she's a you know she's no longer
in congress she's a failed presidential
candidate she only practically exists on
twitter and the fact that we're giving
her oxygen is what makes her relevant
that we're talking about her on hot
topics but on the other hand how do you
not call out something that is repeating
false russian propaganda and that has
been brought down they used to arrest
people for doing stuff like this if they
thought you were
colluding with a russian agent if they
thought you were putting out information
or taking information and handing over
to russia they used to actually
investigate stuff like this and i guess
now you know there seems to be no bars
these people are crazy like they're
legitimately crazy what is whoopi saying
they used to investigate they used to
arrest you oh so we should just start
investigating more people who for wrong
think right um they used to grab them
and put them in jail and gulags and no
trials or anything like that and that
crazy anna navarro who is just she reeks
of being just a horrible horrible person
like what are you saying anna navarro
what what are you really really saying
yes tulsi gabbard is irrelevant she's
only relevant because you talk about her
on on hot topics
and she's a failed presidential
candidate well a she was a congresswoman
uh i believe a two-term congresswoman
who really did
do something relevant during the
campaign she actually stayed in the
campaign longer than anybody else
other than joe biden the machine decided
to choose joe biden but tulsi stayed and
fought as long as she could but if she's
a failed presidential candidate what are
you anna navarro you've worked for a
whole bunch of
people political people as a consultant
who have all failed so so you're you're
nothing but an angry harping you're
awful these people they're just awful
and these are supposedly the people who
are tolerant and they're the ones that
are talking about arresting their
political opponents and on top of the
fact that everything that they're
talking about is based on nonsense
they're they're saying she's parroting
russia propaganda here are the
undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities even in the best of
circumstances could easily be
compromised and release these deadly
pathogens
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens
that they hold need to be destroyed
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden harris administration needs to
work with russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured
and these pathogens are destroyed
now this is not a partisan political
issue
the administration and congress need to
act now for the health and well-being of
every american
and every person on this planet
but we just showed you that actually
what she's referring to is what victoria
nuland is admitting is real that these
bio labs exist